Саме так виглядає успіх.
Усі ці чоловіки очолюють концерни
і заробляють мільйони
І вони – молодші чи старші – доволі привабливі, чи не так?
І, мабуть, це не випадково
Багато досліджень показують
що зовнішня привабливість
та успіх на ринку праці пов'язані
Простими словами, це означає:
чим я привабливіший, тим успішніший
Я ще розумію, коли це стосується
моїх колег-ведучих
В інших випадках - це ж просто дискримінація
Хіба красиві люди краще працюють?
Ні, каже експерт, але всі так вважають
Візьмемо, наприклад, чоловіка –
назвемо його Роберт
Характерне підборіддя, атлетична фігура і передусім - високий
Дуже привабливий чоловік
Його колега, назвемо його Ріхард, невисокий
Йому не дуже пощастило із зовнішністю
Волосся майже не лишилося, схильний до надлишкової ваги
Здебільшого люди вважають Ріхарда не дуже привабливим
Обидва виконують роботу однаково добре
Але гарнішому Роберту
колеги і шеф більше довіряють
Це і є кар'єрною підтримкою
Красивим людям приписують,
що вони більш надійні
більш кооперативні
більш ефективні та розумні
Найгірше, що це замкнене коло
Адже привабливі люди зазвичай
більш упевнені в собі
На думку психологів, це пов’язано з тим, що красиві люди
з дитинства отримують багато позитивних відгуків
І ще більше - якщо чоловік високий
Якщо говорити про розмір тіла
то він у давніші часи
був індикатором якості харчування
Із архівів ми знаємо, що дворянство було
на 10-15 сантиметрів вище за звичайних людей
А це означає - величину тіла
повязували з лідерством
Глибоко вкорінені упередження.
Невже це стосується усіх галузей?
То щоб бути професором університету,
теж треба бути красенем?
Не обовязково.
Але існує дослідження у США
яке показує, що більш привабливі доценти отримують кращі відгуки
Але ви можете бачити на моєму прикладі,
що тут це жодної ролі не грає
Гумор майже завжди допомагає
А також, можливо, перехід на цифрові технології
Адже на IT спеціалістів попит зростає
А справжнім компютерникам байдуже,
як вони виглядають